this framework is not compatible the  genetic coating Towers at 97 percent  you have got to upload that schematic in  the next three minutes  I'm going to say this once how about  nuts shut it down nope not gonna happen  you don't know what you're doing and you  do  she's not in your head I know you're  angry oh we're way past that  I could choke the life out of you and  never change a shade Banner after  everything that's happened nothing  compared to what's coming no it's inside  no no come on  you're saying  what you didn't see that coming  rerouting the upload  [Music]  go ahead piss me off  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]